Here we go.
That's basically it,
and that'll be the reel system
to reel all the line in as that
sled goes up.
All that's left to do
is to string up the cordage.
I gotta couple strands of cord and
going to replace that other cordage
I was using
because that stuff was just too stretchy
It wasn't working well.
Start up at the top.
So I put it through the block and tackle.
I think we're going to get it done.
I had my doubts this morning, but
not so much anymore.
Oh, yoo hoo! Hey.
Hi!
Yup?
Daddy this is so lovely.
It is so lovely.
Good night.
Wow, hon.
You've been working hard.
It is such a good thing
that this generator shed
is done and built.
Next!
And we can get these little generators
back inside.
We don't have to worry.
We're more secure with our electricity.
I think it's cuter than
I thought it was going to be,
but Caleb doesn't build small things,
and he doesn't build ugly things, so
I don't know why I'm surprised.
It's awesome!
That sheet is on.
Are you jumping down
or do you need the ladder?
I'm going to jump.
Oh Gilbert would be so jealous.
Nice roof.
Getting a bite.
Got some lunch RJ.
Good!
Black bomber.
We can keep this and eat it. Nice.
That'll be good.
Oh, yeah.
Yes. You want to open that up for me?
We'll throw them right in the [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, what do you think
about going and trying up
this rockfish for a snack and
heading home?
Sure. Sure.
It was a really beautiful day,
but it's time to go home.
She's going home with some king salmon,
and she's going home with some deer meat
and stuff like that, but
for her to take fish home that we caught
together today, it would have just meant
that much more to her,
knowing she was part of it,
but she's certainly not going to go home
empty-handed.
I'm going to find us a nice, calm place
out of the wind and cook up some rockfish.
It sounds good. I'm hungry.
Let's get out of here. Alright.
You know, we're out on the ocean.
We're out on the land.
We're giving it the utmost respect,
and we're trying to
harvest the animals that we're after
or harvest the fish that we're after.
If we don't get them
we're still out here
living our Alaskan dream.